- [Voiceover] Let's see
if we can find the product
of X minus four, and I'll
put that in parentheses,
the product of that and X plus seven.
And like always, I encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you can figure
it out on your own.
Well there are a bunch of
different ways to tackle
multiplying two binomials like this,
but the way that I like to tackle it,
especially if we're just
learning how to do this
is to just realized that we can apply
the distributive property
that we all know and love.
And how do you do that?
Well you could just think
of this X minus four,
we can distribute the entire binomial.
We can multiply the X
minus four times the X
and we can multiply it times the seven.
So let me rewrite this.
We can rewrite this as,
if we distribute it,
it would be X minus four times this X,
times that blue X and then plus,
we're also distributing the X minus four,
we have to distribute it on
every one of these terms.
So plus X minus four,
X minus four times this seven.
Times the seven.
Now what is this going to
be on the left-hand side?
Well the X times the X
is going to be X squared.
And then the X times, this is minus four,
or X times the negative four is
negative four X.
And then over here I distribute the seven.
Seven times X is seven X.
So plus seven X.
And then seven times
negative four is negative 28.
And now we can simplify this a little bit.
We see that we have
two first degree terms,
two terms where I have
a certain number of Xs
and so we can combine these.
So we have X squared.
If I take these two middle terms,
if I take negative four
X and then add seven Xs,
that's going to give me positive three X.
Negative four plus
seven is positive three.
So positive three X.
And of course we have the,
we have the minus 28.
And we're done.
We just multiplied these two binomials
just using the distributive
property twice.
First we distributed
the entire X minus four
onto the X plus seven, so you got
X minus four times X plus X
minus four times the seven.
And then we distributed
the X onto the X minus four
to get what we see in yellow here.
And we distributed the
seven onto the X minus four
to get what we got in green here.
And then we just simplified a bit.